DANIEL SIEBERG: Hi there.
I'm Daniel Sieberg.
As we continue with our I/O Live
coverage, we are now in
the YouTube space,
and I am joined
by Jason from Flipboard.
Now Flipboard, as a lot of
people will know, is this,
well, you flip through your
content, whether it's news
that's been pulled for
you, social media.
It's got a very distinctive way
of interacting with it.
Tell me how you're here and why
you're here with YouTube?
JASON CULVERHOUSE: Yes.
Well, a couple reasons.
So two weeks ago, a week
ago, we released
Flipboard on Android.
So we're running on the new
Nexus tablet, and the phones
and the phone form factor.
And we did integrations
with both YouTube--
so we're directly accessing
the YouTube data APIs--
and we had early access to the
writeable Google+ APIs.
So now you can interact with
that content, right on
YouTube, right on Google+, leave
comments, +1 stuff, Like
it, and that's why we're here.
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK.
Very cool.
So you've got a demo
you can do for us.
So if you do come across
a YouTube video in your
Flipboard content,
what can you do?
JASON CULVERHOUSE: Yeah.
So I'm a developer, so I do
things like here I'm following
the Google Developers feed.
And if this is a video that I
like, I can just come right
here and I can Like it.
I could play it in our
client full screen.
And I can go and I can
see, hey, here's who
commented on it.
If I want to leave a comment,
I can do that.
And then we sort of do it
in our magazine format.
These are my subscriptions, so
some games and stuff, and some
developer stuff.
But we can also go look at
everything else like the
popular YouTube feeds, what's
trending, what's popular.
You know, trending is
always pretty good.
Like it.
Oh, if I like this video right
here, I can actually just
click right here, and then I
can say, share this video,
right to everybody on
my Google+ account.
And then that video is
going to be shared on
Google+ right now.
And we'll go look at my
feed and we'll see it.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Fantastic.
So tell me about the experience
of working with the
YouTube API, any sort of
learnings or tips you want to
pass along to folks.
JASON CULVERHOUSE: Yeah.
First of all, we got a lot
of help from YouTube.
We did this really quick and
so they're very responsive.
There's a new YouTube API coming
out, so it's useful.
I'd say we learned a lot,
try to be minimal
in our request sizes.
We worked with YouTube
about our quotas, a
very popular app.
A lot of accesses.
So they were very responsive in
helping us with resolving
quota issues and things
like that.
And I'll say the same thing,
the Google+ team.
Because no one really saw this
app and then we released it,
so some of the people on the
Google+ team were, like, our
best QA, because they really
went through it, and they were
the deep Google+ users.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And what's the
response been like to this
since you rolled it out?
JASON CULVERHOUSE:
It's really good.
Just standing here, everybody
comes by, they
say, love it, great.
Of course the most frequent
request is, can we get it on
the tablet form factor?
And right now we're pretty much
the phone form factor,
but it will run on a Android
tablet in that form factor.
But it's been really
positive response.
I think you could see the
downloads on the graph, and we
got a great rating on the
Google Play Store, so
it's all been good.
DANIEL SIEBERG: What's the
future of this, do you think,
for you guys?
Any sort of iterations
coming down the pipe?
JASON CULVERHOUSE: Yeah, I think
there's always lots of
stuff, better UI, more
responsive, we
always like to be faster.
And working with Google to
refine some APIs, because we
have a very specific usage.
So I think all that just leads
to a better user experience.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Cool.
Jason, thank you so much.
We're going to flip
on out of here.
JASON CULVERHOUSE: All right.
Thank you.
DANIEL SIEBERG: All right.
Appreciate it.
All right.
We're joined now by Alex, who
is the creator of Code Hero.
I am not even going to pretend
to be an expert at code, so I
think this might be something
that would work well for me.
ALEX PEAKE: Yeah.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Help me
understand, what is
Code Hero all about?
ALEX PEAKE: So yeah.
Code Hero is a game that teaches
you how to make games.
Do you like games?
DANIEL SIEBERG: Love games.
ALEX PEAKE: Do you want
to learn code?
DANIEL SIEBERG: Do want
to learn code.
ALEX PEAKE: Check.
So you're the target audience.
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK.
ALEX PEAKE: So we've been
asked, who's it for?
Like, middle school is like the
classic group that's going
to most get into games and
learning programming, but
everybody's welcome.
The magic thing about this
is it's actually a game.
It's not like an easier way to
learn programming that's
actually secretly tutorials
with lots of reading.
So it looks like a game.
It is a game.
And you hit, of all, buttons,
New Game, and you're in it.
And what's awesome about this
is that you're being
orientated from the very
beginning in a
first person world.
DANIEL SIEBERG: [INAUDIBLE]
gaming environment.
ALEX PEAKE: Right.
So it's kind of like Tron,
but backwards.
If we made everything dark,
it'd be a little
scary to some kids.
And you pick up these magic
glasses, and it says, type,
click hello world, and
copy that code.
And then when you shoot the
code, it executes, and you go
to the next challenge.
And the next one is
change the code.
So up until now you just copied
the code, but now we
have to type it in.
And so the essence of this is
to walk people step-by-step
through each challenge.
So now they're probably
thinking, OK, is this just a
bunch of text?
The key is to show programming
is fun.
So this is some blocks,
and there's a target.
And it says, just push
the blocks, but
you'll have to add zeros.
So this code here
says, add force,
transform forward 100,000.
That sounds like a lot, but in
the world of physics that's
actually not enough force,
and the cubes
are just not impressed.
But if we add zeros, you realize
code is power and you
can blast these blocks apart.
And you can get that very
quickly in programming, you'll
be able to get the gold star
and accomplish things.
As long as you don't get eaten
by the poison laser lava
safety sharks.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Doctor
Evil would approve.
ALEX PEAKE: Yeah.
And so the integration that we
did with YouTube was based on
the fact that people that are
learning programming are
really going to be proud of what
they're accomplishing,
and they'll want to show
off to their friends.
And especially since the goal
of Code Hero is to make your
own game, to produce
a video game.
That's the first thing you do.
You want to share that game.
And so a long time ago I
thought, wouldn't it be great
if I could upload directly
to YouTube what
the player is doing?
And they wouldn't have to
do that themselves.
And I saw Black Ops
was doing it.
There's tons of videos--
Call of Duty.
Mind Craft had people building
computers and uploading them.
So we implemented at a hackathon
in three days, the
Unity YouTube API,
which wasn't for
Unity, it was just Mono.
All we did was download the
Mono DLL and compile it in
MonoDevelop.
And I made this little cube
where, when you touch this
cube, you won't really
see much happening.
But it's saying add
frame, add frame.
It's recording live video
from the game.
So you'd be able to show people
anything you can learn
in the game, and then they
can learn too, or
anything you can create.
And the end result is, it just
says upload completed.
And this is the first video we
ever uploaded on stage, sort
of crossing our fingers, and
it worked the first time we
ever tried it.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And that's
only four seconds, but of
course it can be much
longer than that.
ALEX PEAKE: Yes.
So the API for YouTube in a
game makes a lot of sense,
because when you learn how
to make a game, you
want to show it off.
When you learn anything, or do
anything cool, you want to
show it off.
And because people are learning
make games with
Unity, they're going to want
this plug-in, which we made,
which is called Unity CapTube.
Sort of like Unity Capture
but with a B.
And Unity CapTube just plugs
into any Unity-based game.
Which is what Code Hero's
teaching them, is the Unity
game engine, which is the most
popular game engine.
You can plug those games into
your Android device, your
web-based games, anything,
native client.
And to be able to upload videos
straight to YouTube
means that your game is going
to spread faster, and more
people are going to see it.
So that's Code Hero.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Help your
game go viral, or
something in the sense.
ALEX PEAKE: Yes.
And hopefully help programming
go viral.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Right.
ALEX PEAKE: You know,
we live in an era
where code is literacy.
English might be our first
language, but we're kind of
like Romans, like, adapting to
English, or we have to get
with the times and learn
programming.
So it's time for programming
to go viral.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's
fantastic.
When can people get their hands
on this, if they want to
check out Code Hero
in a bigger way?
ALEX PEAKE: So what we did
a big Kickstarter.
We raised $170,000,
which was great.
And we're going to be launching
in September the
final version of, like,
the first complete
version of the game.
But you can get it
now if you want.
You can go to the website
at codehero.org.
That's codehero.org.
And if you just buy the game
for whatever donation you
want, just like the Kickstarter
backers, you can
get the same pledge rewards,
like t-shirts and stuff, and
get the game, an early
version, and
try it right away.
DANIEL SIEBERG: This is such a
fantastic idea, I have to say.
This is great.
I wish you all the
best with it.
ALEX PEAKE: Thanks.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Thank
you so much, Alex.
And maybe one day I'll
be a Code Hero, too.
ALEX PEAKE: Thanks.
And thanks for making the
YouTube API awesome.
Our pleasure.
This is seriously really--
The last stop in our tour of the
YouTube booth is with the
guys from Parrot.
And we're talking about
the AR Drone 2.0.
The AR Drone's been around for a
little while, and the reason
that you're here is to talk
about the tie-in with YouTube,
of course, but walk us through
what the AR Drone is capable
of doing first.
PIERRE BUREAU: OK.
So the AR Drone is a flying
device that you can control
from a smartphone or a tablet
running Android or iOS.
And it's embedding a camera.
So well, what's new with the 2.0
version is that you have a
HD camera to record
your videos.
And so it has a lot of sensors,
it's a really smart
device, so it can stabilize
by itself.
Basically that stuff, it's
flying by itself.
So all you got to do is you
press a button, it takes off,
and then it stabilizes
right there.
And in the new version of the
app, we have integrated the
possibility to record and manage
your media, so photos
and videos.
And you can share them online
directly from the app.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Because
that's really cool.
I mean the ability to fly it
in some neat location, and
then share that with everybody
through YouTube, right?
PIERRE BUREAU: Exactly.
Through YouTube.
So everybody can see where your
flights are, what cool
things you have seen, and
you can share that
with the world, basically.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Now, there's a
tie-in with Google TV, that
maybe we should mention
as well?
PIERRE BUREAU: Yeah.
So we just finished an
integration on the new Google
TV, that's also running
Android.
So you can have the video stream
from the drone directly
on your TV, and control
the drone with
the Google TV remote.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So what was it
like working with the YouTube
folks to put all of
this together?
Maybe some learnings you
can offer to the other
developers out there?
PIERRE BUREAU: That was
actually very easy.
The integration of the YouTube
sharing mechanism was very
straightforward, both on
the iOS and Android.
So actually I don't have a lot
of things to say about
possible problems, because
we didn't have any.
And what we're doing is
still quite basic.
We're only doing
online sharing.
Later on, maybe, we'd like to
work with some editing, adding
some music, things like that.
This is still some work in
progress, and we'll use the
YouTube APIs to do that.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Can you tell
me about some of the more
unusual or unique places
that people have
flown their AR Drones?
PIERRE BUREAU: We have users
that have posted videos from
all over the world.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Really?
OK.
PIERRE BUREAU: So we have videos
from the Grand Canyon
in the US, some fjords
in northern Europe.
So really, everywhere.
DANIEL SIEBERG: People
get pretty creative.
PIERRE BUREAU: Yes, they can
get pretty creative,
definitely.
DANIEL SIEBERG: What's
next for--
can you tell us anything
about the next
version of the AR Drone?
PIERRE BUREAU: Well, I can tell
you that we are already
working on the next
generations.
They're not coming out soon.
This has just been released
a couple of weeks ago.
So we have maybe one year, one
year and a half development
time before we can release
a new one.
But we are working on better
videos, better video
capabilities, higher
definitions, things like that.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And tell me
about that camera again.
It was an HD camera
that's on this?
PIERRE BUREAU: Yes.
It's HD camera, 720p camera.
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK.
PIERRE BUREAU: And you can
record your videos through the
Wi-Fi link, or you can plug your
own USB stick inside the
drone so that you have the
perfect quality all the time.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And then when
you want to share it on
YouTube, you do it
through the app?
PIERRE BUREAU: You're doing
it through the app.
Yeah.
So--
DANIEL SIEBERG: How long can
the video clips be that you
want to share through?
PIERRE BUREAU: The
video can be--
DANIEL SIEBERG: As long as the
memory gets [INAUDIBLE]?
PIERRE BUREAU: Yeah, as
long as the memory is.
So you can fly for 10 minutes.
10, 12 minutes, so that's
longest video you can make.
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK.
Well, I think maybe we should
pause here and get a little
demo, what do you think?
PIERRE BUREAU: Yes,
that's good.
DANIEL SIEBERG: All right.
Pierre, thank you so much.
I appreciate it.
PIERRE BUREAU: Thank you.
DANIEL SIEBERG: All right.